[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with
Daily Mirror Economist Susie Boniface
and Deputy comment editor at the
telegraph Annabelle denim they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now well the star
leads with Phillip schofield's
resignation the headline I lied about
affair with young man
that's the same with the mirror leading
with Phil Affair storm
the telegraph leads with Ukraine with a
warning from the outgoing RAF head on
what may happen if Putin loses the war
in Ukraine
the front of the Ft picks up on today's
Sky News exclusive on Chancellor Jeremy
Hunter saying he's comfortable with
Britain being plunged into recession if
that's what it takes to bring down
inflation
and that's the same as the guardian as
they lead with UK set for recession
before next election
the mail leads with an exclusive on
Investigation into the equalities
Watchdog which was suspended last night
amid fears of a Witch Hunt
whilst The Daily Express focuses on the
latest travel chaos as British Airways
faces cancellations
the front of the times leads on foreign
teachers being offered Financial
incentives to work in English schools in
an overseas recruitment Drive
and the eye leads on austerity as a
former Chancellor George Osborne is
summoned to the covid inquiry
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Susie Boniface and Annabelle Denham
welcome to you both um I don't know if
you saw the um Boris Johnson clip before
coming on air I wonder if we could
quickly quickly talk about that Susie I
thought you might have some some
thoughts about that interview
yeah it's an absolutely
astonishing and Brilliant and bizarre
interview that James has managed to get
because as you can see if you've watched
it all the way through at the start
right he's just he's just burst on onto
up to Boris Johnson who does not want to
talk right he's just ignoring him it's
pretending that the camera crew uh isn't
there and the security guards are
pushing them away and then James bless
him does exactly what every Journey
should do it just persists and persists
and persists very politely and very
nicely and keeps asking dick with
questions and eventually Boris Johnson
cannot resist actually responding to
this stuff now if he was a consummate
politician the Tony Blairs of this world
uh John Major even right they would say
nothing right nothing get in get into
the airport where it's private property
and uh just let let the camera crew grow
go away he cannot resist the lure of a
TV camera and eventually he starts
talking and once he starts talking he
can't stop and even when the security
guard sometimes tries to get between
Boris Johnson and the camera and try to
push James and the crew away a bit Boris
Johnson then stops no no no it's okay I
want to carry on talking and then
there's an extended then long discussion
about what's been handed over and
whether or not they asked him but at
first on this kind of stuff and I
suspect we've seen this before we've
seen this before when he was asked over
and over and over again about those
first lockdown parties all the denials
all the things that weren't quite right
then many times that he spoke about it
were the way in in which he eventually
sort of hanged himself and ended up
having to admit criminal liability by
accepting a fine for them and I would
suspect
considering the history of this man and
this issue and these stories that what
James has got out of him here is going
to be an extended kind of the way that
he has hunged himself in in three
different ways by the time he's got to
the end of all this it's all flushed out
and it's all out in in public I would
suspect that the things that are going
to trip Boris up are some of the things
that he has said here off the cuff
without thinking it through because he
couldn't resist the lure of a camera
because he's so desperate for attention
and to be liked which is his fundamental
flaw isn't it Annabelle what did you
make of um what he had to say
um saying that it's absurd that they
passed diary entries to the police the
whole thing's a load of nonsense from
beginning to the end um nothing uh that
he did constitutes rule breaking
foreign people around him have also said
that
this chant and it's like Churchill said
um you're a master of your unspoken word
and a slave to the ones that you've
you've said and you know Boris Johnson
you know Jeff seems to take that advice
uh to Heart Like Susie said these are
words that could well come back to haunt
him he must Wonder uh if it's two years
ago he's uh in number 10 again and all
of the party gate rumors are starting to
swirl around him the difference of
course this time is that he's no longer
our prime minister and it's been made
quite clear he won't be doing a chicken
run at the next German election and is
therefore very likely to lose his seat
and is probably left wondering whether
he's just facing uh time in the abyss
once his political career uh is over now
whether or not he relishes that or
whether he doesn't want it at all
remains to be seen we'll see if he
remains uh in the public sphere after
the next general election but certainly
a very awkward interview for him yes
that was one question that he didn't
answer whether his political career was
over let's move on to the newspapers and
what we've got in front of us this
evening we'll start with the mirror
Susie and their headline Phil Affair
storm your thoughts
yeah this is the result and Ashley and
I'm going to admit right here not of a
mirror exclusive this is something which
um a reporter he used to work for the
people in America Katie hind who's now
at the mail um has managed to land and
the mirror and other papers are picking
it up tonight and again it's another
piece of stonking Journalism she's
managed to find something which has
about this issue about how why and how
Phillips Schofield left this morning
earlier on this week parted ways of his
on-screen wife Holly Willoughby amid
some kind of massive Fallout that no one
really quite understood it all the
excuses and reasons for it never quite
added up and now we've got a statement
from Philip Schofield in which he admits
having an affair while he was married
with someone who worked on the program
with him and uh who we're not going to
identify
um and that he he admits that he's lied
to his agent to his family to his
colleagues he likes the people at ITV
about it and ITV have he's resigned all
his posts there he's not going to be
presenting the soap Awards next week and
even his agents have dumped him now
let's that's one thing put all that to
one side for a moment can anybody think
of any other time when a celebrity has
lied about an affair and they lost every
single job they ever had and their agent
doesn't happen just it just doesn't
happen there are millions of people
who've had affairs who've lied to their
Partners who have lied to their
colleagues about it who have in Showbiz
or in politics who have lied to their
agents about it and that's normal right
that is everyday life
some people
um and the fact that you suddenly have
to quit everything is surprising and
also if you have lied about something
quite big for a very long period of time
you become really invested in it and
you're not about to suddenly go do you
know what that was a lie I wish I hadn't
done that and confessed to the whole
thing unless something has made it
happen and I don't know but I suspect
that what Katie has done here is she's
finally managed to find some kind of
proof which Philip Schofield can no
longer deny he's apologized to her
someone's apologized to a journalist
thank you thank you
um Prince Harry one day maybe
um he's you know that he's managed to
find someone of some way that he's had
to apologize to Katie having lied to her
previously about
um the the stuff that she's you know
presented with him before and he's done
um and this comes in the back of
something else that earlier this week
where
um Zoella bravaman's special advisor was
caught lying to the mirrors political
editor John Stevens about her speeding
farm he seemed to be in a position where
people think it's absolutely let's bring
a question let's bring Annabelle in now
um Susie so Annabelle your thoughts I
mean it seems that the wrongdoing is
that the deceit the fact that he he lied
to employers
um colleagues and and friends that
that's what he's done wrong
yeah absolutely he's been accused of
being a liar and a cheat and I think
it's very difficult with somebody who's
got such a high profile as Phillip
Schofield to uh survive that he became
the story and that made it ultimately
impossible for him to ride it out I mean
I think the first thing to say is that I
have deep empathy for his family I can
only imagine how painful this must be
for them once again they are under the
spotlight facing this intense uh
scrutiny schofield's been lying about
this affair with a young male colleague
um the affair took place while he was
still married to his wife of 30 years he
previously
um had said that it was only a
friendship at the time but obviously
he's subsequently admitted that that was
not
um true thereby ending uh weeks of
increasingly fevered speculation uh in
both TV industry and The Wider country
about uh the future of his career the
future of uh this morning and and you
know perhaps with the gift of hindsight
the writing actually had been on the
wall for some time with Philip
schofield's uh career he's been plagued
with a speculation controversy the
breakdown of his uh relationship with
his on-screen Rife uh Holly Willoughby
um Q gate
um at the queen Lake Queens when she was
laying
um in Westminster
um at the palace of Westminster
um and you know now I think the story is
going to move on to you know whether
there's any
um hope that his career
um might uh be revived at some point in
the future
to prevent the soap Awards and that's
not happening yes I mean definitely not
not with them with with ITV for the
moment all projects with them are
canceled let's move on just try and fill
in another
story
um Susie this is also on the front of
the mail an investigation into the
equalities Watchdog has been suspended
tell us why
um I don't know because I didn't know we
were going to talk about that so I
haven't read it oh okay well um I can
say that I got sent sorry
well the males are exposure an apparent
plot by staff to Alfred kishwa Faulkner
over her stance on trans issues but we
shall return to that story when you have
read it in the meantime I think we've
got time just to have a look at this
story in the times uh Tita family visa
rules on cards to ease immigration
um can we talk about that one Susie
yes definitely
so this is a one of these couple of
dichotomous stories in a way in page
four of the times here we've got claims
which has been trailed during the week
from the home office saying they're
going to stop students bringing in
relatives uh when they get a visa to
study here because again there's too
many migrants coming in and that's the
reason for all the problems that we've
got and actually on page one of the
times and at the bottom of this story
here there is another story talking
about how they're going to bring in
foreign teachers from all around the
world from the Commonwealth to teach
here because we've got to teach a
shortage problem which is leading to all
the strikes of course and of course
teachers generally tend to have families
and they're going to have to bring those
with them as well so in the one hand
we're going to stop those people coming
in on the other hand oh God we need some
people to come in or they can bring
their whole family so that's absolutely
fine the chaos we've got in our
immigration system uh Rich large there
on page one and Page four of the times
Annabelle you've got about 30 seconds
but a lot of criticism on the um Family
visa rules I.E they're targeting the
wrong entirely the wrong people
well I think you know it's very
difficult like Susie says you do have
the structural position of the
government wanting to clamp down on net
migration has been an extremely awkward
uncomfortable week for them with the net
migration date of 2022 coming out
revealing that net migration stats were
um at 606
000 in 2022 but at the same time there
are shortages of Labor in certain
occupations that's why the government
has this list tries to specifically
recruit people
um particular jobs